pittsburgh has been revitalizing itself
through technology for a very long time
there is a reason that u.s. steel tower
is now also the corporate home of the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
because the Steel City is now home to
groundbreaking medical research this
positions Carnegie Mellon University
like no other university to work at the
critical intersection of technology and
human behavior it is there that we can
create innovations that enhance lives
and it is there that we can foresee and
plan for the unintended consequences
that such a revolutionary change brings
when machine learning became a common
technique that all these different
fields started using to improve in
computer vision to improve and speech
recognition to improve in even robotics
to build an entity that can combine the
all the abilities all the subtasks of
vision and speech and so on and that's
actually a partly what the excitement of
today is in AI so data allows you to
personalize things at scale and we can
now personalized policies health
policies criminal justice policies
education policies economic development
policies job training policies and we
should do that at the same time we
should make sure that it's actually
personalized for everyone in a way
that's equitable and fair the robots are
essential robots and support human
missions are robots at work and some of
the good news is that all these things
are parallel agenda here on earth where
they are huge markets and there's lots
more of that to come the incoming class
in computer science this year is full of
people who just espanish me because they
really care about the world it is such
an exciting time to be a nerd who cares
innovation is in our DNA science has
always been central to our progress and
it's playing a leading role in
overcoming so many of our greatest
challenges that's as true today as it's
ever been only with science can we make
a shift to cleaner sources of energy and
take steps to save the only planet we
have